[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bienvenue ses sens public 90 minutes de
débat de reportages et des expertises
sur public sénat je vous donne rendez
vous tous les jours du lundi au jeudi à
18 heures et à 22 heures avec la même
ambition que la saison dernière donner
du sens à l'actualité et voici les
titres de ce 7 septembre elle s'appelle
lise c'est la 56e le 56e premier
ministre britannique la troisième femme
à ce poste elle a prononcé aujourd'hui
son premier discours devant la chambre
des communes
je vais prendre des actions immédiates
pour aider les gens avec leurs factures
d'énergie mais je sécuriserait aussi nos
ressources sur le long terme je vais
prendre des actions immédiates pour
m'assurer de faire baisser les impôts et
croître notre économie et je vais
m'assurer que nous ayons un figure
positive pour notre pays et que nous
fassions avancer la grande bretagne mais
qui élit stress cette conservatrice
aura-t-elle la même poignée que margaret
thatcher quel sera l'effet de cette
nomination sur les relations franco
britanniques nos experts répondront dans
deux minutes et puis si vous êtes un
fidèle de sens public vous savez qu'on
aime prendre du recul sur les événements
et cette semaine on analyse en
profondeur les grands chantiers de cette
rentrée pour le gouvernement après
l'énergie et l'assurance chômage ou
propose trois quarts d'heures de débat
sur la planification écologique quelles
leçons faut-il tirer de cet été de
sécheresses de canicules d' incendies et
de violents orages le changement
climatique est déjà là comment concilier
l'urgence et le temps long le défi est
énorme
mais d'abord donc le portrait l'histoire
signé sam yards de chiens
monsieur le président je suis honoré de
prendre ma place de premier ministre
dans cette maison c'est une maison
qu'elle connaît bien listre 47 ans s'est
imposé à la tête de l'exécutif
britannique
l'aboutissement d'un long parcours
ministériel
entrée au gouvernement en 2012 elle a
depuis enchaîné les ministères jusqu'à
celui des affaires étrangères qu'elle
occupait jusqu'au départ de boris
johnson à qui elle est restée fidèle
jusqu'au bout et c'est elle que le parti
conservateur a choisi pour lui succéder
une femme aux profils très libéral j'ai
un plan audacieux pour faire croître
l'économie grâce aux baisses d'impôts et
aux réformes je baisserais les impôts
pour récompenser le travail et stimuler
la croissance générée par les
entreprises et les investissements une
rigueur budgétaire qui rappelle une
certaine margaret thatcher listre
s'assume comme l'héritière de la dame de
fer et cultive la ressemblance avec
celle qui brisait les grèves des mineurs
dans les années 70
cet été pendant sa campagne elle affiche
la même intransigeance face aux
syndicalistes alors que le royaume uni
est paralysé par des grèves contre la
vie chère
il n'est pas normal d'essayer de prendre
les transports publics en otage
j'adopterai une ligne dure avec les
actions des syndicats si elles ne sont
pas bonnes pour les gens pourtant les
strauss n'a pas toujours été cette
figure ultra libérale issue d'une
famille de gauche elle est entrée en
politique par la porte du centrisme chez
les libéraux démocrates
avant de rejoindre les conservateurs
quelques années plus tard sous ses airs
inflexible elle est capable de retourner
sa veste comme elle l'a fait pour le
break site ce que vous devez retenir de
liste chose c'est que bien qu'elle ait
fait campagne contre le bric site au
moment du référendum dès que le résultat
a eu lieu elle a accepté al'inverse de
beaucoup d'autres politiciens elle a
commencé à travailler pour faire aboutir
le break site la tâche de liste ross
s'annonce difficile elle prend la tête
d'un pays où l'inflation dépasse les 10%
alors que le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
dégringole et les scandales du
gouvernement précédent ont érodé la
confiance des britanniques en leurs
dirigeants
les 4 vérités de l'histoire on en parle
tout de suite avec mes invités sarah
pickard bonjour bienvenue vous êtes
maîtresse de conférences en civilisation
britannique contemporaine à l'université
sorbonne nouvelle j'accueille également
patrick martin geniez bonsoir bienvenue
spécialisé questions européennes et
enseignant à sciences po sacha mitchell
bonsoir bienvenue mon sens rédacteurs
royaume uni à courrier international
matthieu croissandeau est à mes côtés il
sera inscrit tic bonsoir mathieu et puis
avec mon duplex sylvie bermann ancienne
ambassadrice de france à londres bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi en poste pendant
trois ans au royaume uni en pleine
campagne du référendum pour le break
site alors je commence le 1er chapitre
vraiment assez on va dire personnel on
va parler politique évidemment
longuement mais vraiment sur la
personnalité de l'istrie sarah pickard
qu'est ce qui vous frappe chez elle
ce qui me frappe le plus c'est comment
il a retourné sa veste à comment viens
d'entendre c'est quelqu'un qui est issu
d'une famille à gauche qui a voté contre
pour rester dans l'union européenne qui
a changé d'avis qui était dans un autre
parti avant mais qui change avec les
temps mais qui est ambitieuse mais qui
est une personne qui communiquent qu'une
façon de communiquer assez étrange c'est
à dire
qui est très maladroite souvent et qui
qui n'est pas diplomate malgré le fait
que jusqu'à hier elle était ministre des
affaires étrangères qui pensent qu'elle
est capable de faire plein de choses
mais qui ne pensent pas derrière tout ce
que cela implique donc c'est quelqu'un
certain ambitieuse on est mais pas
peut-être le plus adapté à sa façon de
penser l'économie et d'autres choses on
y reviendra évidemment en détaille
patrick martin je n'y ai je dois vous
féliciter alors est-ce que juste avant
les vacances des missions de présenter
d'ailleurs mathieu sur l'après boris
johnson vous aviez
pariez en quelque sorte la victoire de
deux listes rusk qu'est ce que vous
diriez là aussi du personnage en dehors
de l'analyse politique on y viendra
juste après écoutez c'est une femme qui
a beaucoup de caractère et ça c'est très
important pour gouverner un pays et donc
c'est la troisième femme première
ministre
elle arrive dans des circonstances tout
à fait exceptionnelles mais comme vous
l'avez dit c'est quelqu'un qui est
capable de retourner sa veste qui est un
des grands opportunisme et donc
politique on l'a bien vu les mêmes
jusqu'à allait proposer lorsqu'elle
était jeune de supprimer la royauté
évidemment ça a dû lui faire étrange de
rencontrer la reine d'angleterre hier
quelqu'un voit là et qui a un gros
problème de communication elle vient de
leur côté un nouveau conseil en
communication
parce qu'elle est capable de dire
beaucoup de choses qui choque et
notamment le fait que les ouvriers
britanniques n'étaient pas assez
productif et qu'en plus ces ouvriers de
londres était plus productif que les
ouvriers province donc à force de faire
un certain nombre je veux dire de gaffes
comme cela en fait elle a eu le soutien
de la frange la plus nationalistes et
populistes du parti conservateur et onu
a pas voulu de cela pourquoi parce
qu'elle est sur une ligne très dur mais
on y reviendra aussi mais une petite
anecdote un peu plus people une anecdote
boucles d'oreilles on va dire que je
suis cette liste mais ça a du sens
pourquoi oui part parce que je les lui
dans la presse britannique c'est pas du
tout sexiste c'était des critiques de
deux candidats en fait c'est quelqu'un
qui est issu des classes d'une classe me
direz peu modeste populaire et donc
effectivement et bien la presse
britannique a regardé ses boucles
d'oreilles qui valent elles environ de 4
livres 50 à plus 5 euros tandis que
ruessi sauna qui le représentant de
l'élite fêtait son principal concurrent
principal que rendront donc au poste de
premier ministre est issu d'une famille
très riche à sa femme éprouvée la plus
riche d'angleterre et naturellement il
portait des chaussures qui coûtait 500
euros la paire de chaussures donc on a
bien vu que cela même si c'est un peu
anecdotique on montre bien que et bien
il y a quelqu'un qui représente l élite
très riche qui n'était pas au contact de
la population d'ailleurs issus hanak
avaient dit qu'ils n'avaient aucune
relation dans le milieu des salariés et
des ouvriers tandis qu'ali stress malgré
sa libéral c'est quelqu'un qui est issu
d'un milieu modeste et qui a su le
montrer et donc avoir le soutien de la
base du parti conservateur alors sacha
mitchell un peu la même question qu'est
ce qui revient peut-être dans la presse
britannique
dans les portraits que la presse
britannique le consacre le par exemple
tient sur la question du charisme ce
qu'elle est jugée charismatique elle
n'est pas forcément jugé très
charismatique mais c'est ce qui a plu en
fait aussi aux militants du parti
conservateur ça répliquèrent d'évoquer
son côté son côté gauche sa diction un
petit peu haché qui rappelle d'ailleurs
un peu boris johnson elle s'est inscrite
dans cette continuité politique est la
lll a été très loyal aussi ça a été ça a
été rappelée elle n'a pas démissionné
lorsque tout le gouvernement les 60
ministres secrétaires d'état ont
démissionné début juillet et ont
provoqué la chute de boris johnson ll
est resté jusqu'au bout et ça ça a plu
aux militants du parti conservateur qui
l'ont choisi la loyauté elle remonte
aussi avant elle remonte à la au mandat
de theresa may parce que après le break
site effectivement est là elle a
retourné sa veste elle s'est découvert
une fibre très propres excitée elle a
voté tous les plans de sortie de l'union
européenne de theresa may alors que
chaque vague venait s'écraser contre le
parlement britannique c'est cette
loyauté c'est ce côté effectivement
proche proche du peuple aussi et c'est
cette ténacité qui est beaucoup relevées
dans les dents les dans les portraits
qui sont publiés à son propos dans la
presse britannique mais aussi
effectivement le côté
on ne sait pas en fait on ne sait pas
quel du stress on va avoir au pouvoir on
ne sait pas quelles vont être les
scellés sont vierges et les buts alors
on va continuer de voilà de d'enrichir
ce poste ce portrait avec avec vous
sylvie bermann j'ai oublié de vous poser
la question en préparant les missions
est ce que vous avez eu l'occasion de la
rencontrer peut-être pas d'ailleurs elle
était peut-être pas encore elle avait
peut-être pas encore de 2 d'envergure
politique suffisante pour que là vous
les rencontriez à l'époque vous étiez
ambassadrice
non en fait je ne pense pas l'avoir
rencontrée mais je ne suis même pas sûr
je crois qu'elle est ministre de la
justice à ce moment là
donc non je ne la connais pas du tout
personnellement ce qui est frappant là
c'est que boris johnson
se voyait un whist tshatshi les elle se
voit on margaret thatcher et donc elle
se présente déjà comme une nouvelle dame
de fer s'est toujours là la référence
des ultra libéraux il faut pas oublier
en fait que dans toute sa campagne il
s'est adressé à la droite du parti et
plus break sitter au plus
favorable à une économie ultra-libérale
mais c'est entre 160 mille deux cent
mille personnes ça ne veut pas dire
d'ailleurs qu'elle sera très populaire
au sein des députés et puis parmi des
membres du parti d'en rire qui n'ont pas
nécessairement
voter pour elle il y en a même qui
aurait souhaité déjà que ce soit ben
johnson qui reste à son poste ou qui
reviennent donc elle n'aura pas une
tâche s ça pose la question de sa
légitimité on l'évoquera ensemble quand
on prépare l'émission j'ai demandé aux
uns et aux autres si vous aviez des
anecdotes tout est alors il ya beaucoup
d'histoires de fromage qui sont qui sont
ressortis c'est certainement lié à cette
vidéo regarder
n'importe neuf dixièmes de nos poire oui
on emporte deux tiers de nos fromages
c'est une
c'est la façon dont elle a scandé
c'est un pic à date et 10 grèce qui a
marqué il ya eu plein de caricatures
dans les médias sociaux mais au-delà de
ça ça dit quelque chose de son
personnage quand même oui je vais
recommander ses clips qui continue parce
qu'elle part du port elle par du fromage
des poires et c'est une façon de parler
mais aussi elle essaye de donner une
image d'elle mais n'est qu'ils
raisonnent pas et on a évoqué combien de
personnes ont voté c'est même ses 80 en
mille personnes qui ont voté pour elle
permet les adhérents
à quoi 170000 à peu près adhérents et on
a 80 milles qui sont les plus militants
les plus à droite les plus un profit
plutôt masculin classes moyennes dans le
sud de l'angleterre blanc des hommes et
donc c'est une partie de la population
qui est minime par rapport à tout ce
qu'elle doit faire elle était même pas
élu parmi les députés at-il loin
derrière chi sounac donc les confronter
elle avoue sa clinique et les cas
millions elle change elle a changé son
discours envers les députés après parmi
les adhérents et maintenant elle va
encore changer son discours envers la
population pour plaire parce qu'elle a
une envie de ressembler à manga saturé
et bien sûr mais c'est quelqu'un qui
n'est pas fiable dans le sondages auront
dit les gens qui ne font pas confiance
en elle parce que quelqu'un qui change
tout le temps comme ça qui est capable
de dire de lettres démagogues dédiant ce
qui plaît on n'a pas besoin de ça
effectivement elle démarre on peut on
peut montrer ce sondage sur que tu
allumes surgi
pour 52% des britanniques
l'histoire sera la pire des premiers
ministres donc on fait dire que l'élan
n'est pas n'est pas gigantesque on va
dire ça comme ça on va on va parler de
son positionnement politique un peu plus
en détails mathieu alors vous avez été
frappée vous par la diversité de son
gouvernement c'est effectivement
intéressant oui en lisant après 5 comme
tout le monde je suis tombé sur un
article publié par le site de radio
france internationale qu'ils aient pour
la première fois son histoire le royaume
uni ne compte pas d'hommes blancs aux
quatre postes les plus importants de son
gouvernement et je n'ai pas fait de
recherche exhaustive mais je pense que
on aurait pu même ajouté que c'est sans
doute une première en europe alors de
fait il ya liste re5 est la troisième
femme à accéder aux deux hôtels downing
street après mariah de cette chaire 13
mai et canaux mais une de ses proches
aux postes de vice premier ministre et
puis il ya trois ministres qui qui sont
particulièrement sous les projecteurs
coisy karting et 47 ans qu'est le
premier chancelier de l'échiquier noir
fils d'immigrés arrivés du ghana dans
les années 60 on était déjà ministre
dans le gouvernement précédent il ya un
souhait la brève herman 42 ans qui elle
hérite de l'intérieur les parents de
cette ancienne avocate était d'origine
indienne et il ya james river licka 53
ans dont la mère est originaire du
sierra leone et qui lui est nommé au
foreing office savoir une sacrée leçon
quand sous se souvient que le pays a
connu son premier membre du gouvernement
en noir en 2002 sous tony blair
que de chemin parcouru en vingt ans et
on peut aussi que c'est une leçon pour
nous d'une certaine façon assurément non
pas qu'il n'y ait jamais eu de femme ou
de personnalités issues de la diversité
dans nos gouvernants rappelle que la
france compte aujourd'hui une femme
première ministre pour la deuxième fois
de son histoire qu'un fils de sénégalais
pape ndiaye occupé le portefeuille de
l'éducation nationale qui les seconds et
par une secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse
qui est elle la fille de 2,2 de parents
d'origine marocaine ou encore que l'ami
de la culture possède la double
nationalité française et libanaise mais
tout de même quand vous faites la liste
des principaux portefeuilles en france
économie intérieur justice armée on peut
dire que le mâle blanc est encore bien
représenté et puis si tu ne le sont
aussi pour nous parce qu'on a souvent
dénigré de ce côté de la manche le
modèle communautariste britannique en
lui opposant notre fameux modèle
d'intégration à la française qui ne
reconnaîtrait que des individus citoyens
et non pas des représentants des
communautés mais force est de constater
que le royaume uni qui compte aussi
rappelons le un maire de londres qui est
d'origine pakistanaise et et musulman
n'a pas de leçon à recevoir en termes
d'intégration dans la classe politique
par rapport à la france en terme d'image
pour la population britannique comme
pour la population européenne ce sont là
deux sacrés par ce symbole donc ça c'est
pour la composition la personnalité
l'origine des principaux ministres mais
alors sur le plan politique ce
gouvernement multicolore du point de vue
de la diversité ethnique j'ai envie de
dire est incroyablement monocolore sur
le point de vue des idées parce que
liszt reus a constitué une équipe de
conservateurs libéraux ultra libéraux
pur jus coisy karting le nouveau
chancelier de l'échiquier qui est un
diplômé 10 tonnes de cambridge quand
même passé à revendre je crois est un
pur produit de l'élite il est décrit
comme un ultralibéral
admirateurs lui aussi de margaret
thatcher et coauteur d'un livre qui
qualifiait les britanniques de pire
fainéants au monde
quentin sous la braise herman elle est
aussi passée par cambridge elle devra
gérer l'épineux dossier des migrants et
à l'applaudir demain le souhait du
précédent gouvernement d'envoyer vous
savez des migrants au rwanda et puis
elle est aussi décrite comme une anti
watch ardente et puis quant à james
cleverly en charge la diplomatie
britannique lui c'est un break sitter
convaincu d'une loyauté à toute épreuve
envers liste reste comme quoi dans le
gouvernent d'entre eux sont peu voire
que diversité ethnique ne rime pas
forcément avec diversité politique
comment on peut la définir politiquement
ultralibéral avant mais justement je
viens pour se compléter ce qui vient
d'être dit il ya un paradoxe à d'été ici
elle même d'un milieu modeste et
populaire et je vais redire les chiffres
70% des membres de son gouvernement du
cabinet comment d'héroïne et sont issus
des grandes écoles alors qu'elle même a
fait quand j'ai des grandes écoles et
des écoles privées quand elle a fait une
école publique alors donc voyez c'est un
peu paradoxal donc pour comment définir
son gouvernement extrêmement libérale
elle a dit une phrase lorsqu'elle a été
élue première ministre lorsqu'il ya eu
les résultats elle a dit j'ai fait une
campagne de conservatrice et donc je
vais gouverner en conservatrices donc
naturellement elle veut apparaître comme
la nouvelle margaret thatcher elle est
en lutte idéologique presque contre les
syndicats à la dic c'est eux qui faisait
du mal au pays elle a refusé encore ce
matin à la chambre des communes de
s'engager pour une limitation du coût de
l'énergie ou une
attaque
j'étais limité la taxe est enfin là la
galaxie de facture énergétique pour les
ménages mais elle refuge un impôt
exceptionnel et elle veut à département
comment l'équation va être extrêmement
d'ici là pas sûr elle devrait annoncer
demain mais si elle gèle les tarifs du
gaz ou de l'électricité ça peut coûter
très très cher ça parle de 150 milliards
d'euros donc tout à fait c'est
vertigineux il va bien falloir trouver
de l'argent et on sait très bien que ya
environ 10 à 15 millions de foyers
britanniques qui vont être dans la
pauvreté énergétique très rapidement si
elle ne retourne pas sa veste encore une
fois c'est à dire qu'elle ne renie pas
toutes ses idées idéologique qu'elle a
annoncé lors de la campagne elle va
devant de graves difficultés alors on va
vous les uns les autres plutôt critique
on va lui donner la parole une autre
fois dans ce dans ce débat c'est un
autre extrait de l'un de ses premiers
discours pour annoncer son plan pour
l'économie justement
j'ai un plan audacieux pour faire
croître l'économie grâce aux baisses
d'impôts et aux réformes je baisserais
les impôts pour récompenser le travail
et stimuler la croissance générée par
les entreprises et les investissements
je mènerai des réformes dans le cadre de
ma mission pour que le royaume uni
travail se renforce et se développe oui
ou non retroussons les manches pour nous
assurer que la population ne se
retrouvera pas face à des factures
d'énergie inabordable et nous nous
assurerons aussi de construire des
hôpitaux des écoles des routes et le
haut débit
sylvie bermann je reviens vers vous
parce que c'est intéressant on l'a on
discutait de ces premières annonces qui
devrait être fait demain autour du du
coût de l'énergie on vient de dire
qu'elle est ultra libérale mais elle va
sans doute devoir manger son chapeau
libéral tout de suite en affichant un
état protecteur ou un état providence
avec des mesures de soutien aux familles
confrontées à la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
oui tout à fait mais le royaume uni est
dans une situation qui est
particulièrement mauvaises en ce qui est
pire que celle des autres européens
les choses se sont d'ailleurs dégradées
depuis le 26 il faut quand même se
rappeler que l'année à vendre excite le
royaume uni était le pays qui avait le
taux de croissance le plus élevé dans
l'union européenne et au sein du g7
d'ailleurs également et
qui avait pratiquement pas d'inflation
non plus et le plein emploi donc les
choses se sont détériorées depuis ce
sont encore plus détériorées récemment
avec les augmentations astronomiques du
prix de l'énergie d'autres connaissent
aussi puisque aucune mesure n'a été
prise ça va être beaucoup plus difficile
où tout dans son programme et
contradictoire c'est ce qu'elle ait dit
d'ailleurs enrichi sous mac qui lui n'a
pas été entendu pour d'autres raisons
parce que c'est à la fois des baisses
d'impôts mais en même temps on va aider
les hôpitaux donc comment avec quoi
là il y aurait déjà des aides aux
familles bon j'ai le prix effectivement
allergies se renier si elle ne fait pas
ça ça va être une catastrophe parce
qu'il y a déjà pratiquement tout tous
les corps de métiers qui sont en grève
aujourd'hui des docteurs même juste rose
avocat donc elle va faire face à une
situation exceptionnellement difficile
sacha mitchell que qu'est-ce qui est-ce
qui bruissent dans la dans la presse
britannique justement sur les premières
mesures annoncées par
par les stress c'est cette histoire de
gel des tarifs des vestiaires j ce qui
est intéressant c'est que justement les
les conseillers économiques de margaret
thatcher ont pas mal été interviewé ces
derniers temps dans la presse
britannique et ils ont dit attention les
années 80 c'était un contexte très
particulier les baisses d'impôts impôt
sur les sociétés impôt sur le revenu ce
sont
ont été décrétés dans un contexte très
particulier qui est complètement
différent de celui auquel on assiste
actuellement donc ça sera très compliqué
pour elle en tout cas de mettre en
oeuvre ces baisses d'impôts notamment
encore plus dans un contexte d'inflation
qui va créer un déséquilibre donc le gel
des prix qui étaient demandés déjà par
les travaillistes depuis quelques
semaines semble quasiment quasiment
inéluctable là maintenant mais ça ne
coûtera encore une fois je me répète
mais paradoxal pour une femme qui pour
une plutôt un état faible le le le
laisser le marché faire son travail
enfin voilà elle est libérale ou ultra
libérale elle parler
aux militants du parti conservateur elle
parlait aussi à la presse conservatrice
qui était très contente de voir
quelqu'un se réclamer de margaret
thatcher et assumer un libéralisme et
un amour pour le
libre marché puisque on a parlé de ces
retournements de veste mais ça c'est une
constante son admiration de margaret
thatcher elle remonte à oxford elle
remonte même un peu avant et elle elle
était dans le cercle
friedrich hayek qui était un économiste
libéral des des sons l'époque où elle
était au chez les libéraux démocrates
donc ça ça a beaucoup plu à la presse
conservatrice mais maintenant
effectivement il va falloir se
confronter à la réalité de deux du
secteur de l'énergie aussi britannique
est très particulier qui est très
morcelé qui est très éclatée qui a été
libéralisé justement par margaret
thatcher dans les années 80 et qui on a
assisté là depuis un an même avant la
guerre en ukraine à des faillites de
petits de petits fournisseurs d'énergie
qui en fait
n'arrivait pas à faire face parce que il
était obligé de mon d'augmenter les prix
de manière démesurée et ça ça va être le
problème de fond auquel il va falloir
aussi se confronter une fois une fois
arrivé au pouvoir oui il ya le compare à
vous la comparaison à qu'elle fait même
d'ailleurs assez évidente un peu facile
avec margaret thatcher patrick martin
geniez est ce que c'est une nouvelle
dame de fer est ce que vous dites à côté
on à margaret thatcher effectivement en
mémoire qui restait très populaire dans
la mémoire des britanniques mais pas
tous ou fatou c'est vrai parce que sa
statue dans son village natal il ya une
statue qui étaient érigés elle est
immédiatement tags et malheureusement on
va dire mais tout le monde n'est pas une
dame de fer mais attention faut pas être
sexiste non plus il ya des hommes qu'aux
côtés des astres hub johnson a été
mauvais ceci dit il ya une dame de fer
theresa may sans être sexiste a été un
peu la dame de plombs parce que tout ce
qu'elle a entrepris a échoué
donc on verra quel type de dames
première ministre ça peut être tout le
monde n'a pas les moyens d'être margaret
thatcher je rappellerai quand même que
margaret thatcher à gouverner plus de
dix ans qu'elle a remporté plusieurs
élections successivement elle a dû
partir à la demande expresse du parti
conservateur donc theresa may n'est
resté que trois ans et distress
finalement ne devrait rester au grand
maximum deux ans parce que les
prochaines élections ont lieu en 2024 et
je pense qu'elle arrive dans une
situation extrêmement périlleuse et je
ne pense pas qu'elle puisse faire des
miracles et donc je ne pense pas que ce
sera une nouvelle dame de fer sauf que
elle est très rigide sur ses
orientations idéologiques et c'est en
cela quoi peut-être dire effectivement
que ben elle s'inspire nettement de
magath sarah pickard ya quand même dans
le parallèle il ya effectivement le fait
de deux d'arriver au pouvoir dans un
pays confronté à de nombreuses grèves à
de nombreux métiers en grève on se
souvient du bras de fer de marianne
thatcher avec les mineurs évidemment ça
a été un
un axe peut-être fondateur un acte
fondateur peut-être deux de ces mandats
donc est ce que vous voyez là une
possibilité qu'elles s'inscrivent dans
cette tradition par rapport aux
syndicats oui la grève des mineurs a
duré plus d'un an des 84 5 qui revient
après le iv admis mécontentement entre
78 et 79 qui a fait venir ça tient au
pouvoir mais je peux dire que disent tu
as est lui encore plus dur par rapport
aux syndicats elle a dit qu'elle allait
interdire les grèves et parmi les
services publics essentiels qui est
quand même en droit fondé frontale aux
travailleurs de faire grève mais c'est
encore une fois c'est l'image des c2
être dur mais c'est à dire aussi que
toutes les personnes les ya plein de
métiers et de professions qui sont en
grève depuis plusieurs mois et c'est
difficile te fait grève en angleterre tu
fis la législation passait pas saturer
ses successeurs il faut le faire un
préavis il faut faire un vote il faut à
peu près dans un autre préavis donc
c'est très long donc elle essaye d'être
dur mais ça va être très compliqué pour
elle est juste j'aimerais lui revenir ce
que vous avez dit sur les diversités de
son cabinet le ministre intérieur
affaires étrangères et des finances
certes une diversité mais au fait les
trois personnes ont été éduqués dans le
privé mais horse seulement 7% des
enfants sont indiquées dans le privé en
angleterre donc c'est une méritocratie
qui ressemble absolument attaque hier
que tu te donner les places aux
personnes qui ont du mérite donc qu'on
vit bien sûr que c'est formidable
d'avoir un site déjà cités mais c'est
encore une fois c'est c'est la
différence est basé sur les classes
sociales et les ressources et non pas
tout le monde n'a pas cette possibilité
d'aller dans les écoles privées y
compris croisic watan qui tient eaton je
crois donc qu'on fait c'est les mêmes
choses que boris johnson c'est vrai et
david cameron et ainsi de suite donc
faut faire attention à
aa
cet aspect socio-économique qui est
important pour mon match j'ai une
question est ce qu'elle est à l'image du
pays l'opinion depuis parce qu'on a
décrit sur une ligne y compris au sein
du parti conservateur très libérale très
dur or vous rappelez peut-être un aux
téléspectateurs qu'elle a été désigné
que par les militants un petit nombre de
maladies rares en garde de la population
aux britanniques de la famille
challenges en termes voilà deux 2es que
politiquement à l'image du pays où est
ce qu'il va y avoir un hiatus et ça va
casser 0 3% à peu près de l'électorat
effectivement ça la presse britannique
l'a rappelé beaucoup deux fois pendant
la campagne c'est les règles de la du
système politique britannique
le chef de la majorité devient premier
ministre après c'est de cette manière
que boris johnson avait déjà accédé au
pouvoir en 2019 et six mois plus tard on
avait des élections législatives
pour le moment dans la presse
britannique et on parle beaucoup plus de
l'urgence on lui souhaite bon courage
d'ailleurs dans la presse britannique
que ce soit chez les travaillistes sur
la presse proche des travaillistes avec
un petit peu de en espérant que des
élections soient soient appelés assez
assez rapidement mais il ya quand même
ce bruit de fond est ce que à terme dans
les six mois dans l'année à venir il va
y aller il va y avoir une élection parce
que c'est aussi comme ça logique pour
aller chercher une légitimité qui
aujourd'hui est faible boris johnson
l'avait fait parce qu'il l'avait pensé
comme une référendum sur sa vision du
bric side sur un arbre xceed ça avait
été un triomphe pour lui à l'époque en
décembre 2019
maintenant effectivement est-ce que
est ce que ça sera le cas dans l'année à
venir si justement la situation ne se
résout pas parce que les conservateurs
ont aucun intérêt à ça dans les sondages
ils sont encore entre 10 et 15 points
derrière les travaillistes c'est ce
serait un gros pari pour je vous donne
la parole tout de suite on va on va
parler de des relations franco
britanniques dans un instant avec
quentin qu'elle même et une info quand
même on parle du scepticisme de
l'opinion avec le sondage que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure 52% les britanniques qui
disent qu'elle sera la pire des premiers
ministres puis aussi le scepticisme des
marchés financiers la livre sterling a
ensuite au plus bas depuis
1985 face au dollar et que la crainte
d'une éventuelle récession patrick
martin geniez c'est peu dire que la
planche d'appel est un peu friable quoi
ah oui parce qu'en guise de bienvenue
c'est extrêmement extrêmement périlleux
quoi voilà effectivement vous l'aviez la
livre qui est au plus bas depuis 1985
en guise d'accueil sur les marchés
financiers ont fait mieux quand même
vous l'avez dit les sondages ne sont
absolument pas favorable dont cali
stress pourquoi boris johnson at il
gagné mais il a gagné une hyper majorité
parce qu'il avait dit je vais faire le
break site on a vu les conditions dans
lesquelles il l'a fait après en tout cas
il a réussi son pari rappelez vous je
vais faire le break cité et réussi haut
la main ces élections législatives donc
seul boris johnson avait une excellente
popularité est une vraie légitimité
politique que n'a pas aujourd'hui 10
trusts ce matin vous citez les sondages
je regardais en maman qui avait ce débat
à la chambre des communes les
travaillistes avaient environ entre sept
et huit points d'avancé sur le parti
conservateur en cas d'élection ce qui
veut dire que aujourd'hui le stress est
là ou bien l intérêt qu aucun des
élections mme herremans n'est pas
légitime puisqu'elle a été élue par 160
mille membres du parti conservateur elle
n'a absolument aucun intérêt à dissoudre
la chambre des communes parce que ce
serait une défaite électorale majeure
donc elle va essayer de se construire
une légitimité dans les mois qui
viennent et dès lors qu'elle sortira qu
éventuellement et bien les choses lui
sont favorables soit elle dissoudra soit
elle gardera le timing électorale soit
2000 alors comme promis jour un nouveau
chapitre dans ce débat chapitre consacré
aux relations franco britannique quentin
calmez vous pouvez nous
rejoindre l'iss trust s'est déjà fait
remarquer pour une petite phrase on soit
content
emmanuel macron c'était cet été deux
semaines avant son élection au poste de
premier ministre voilà une petite phrase
prononcée sur le ton de la plaisanterie
mais qui en dit beaucoup sur l'état
d'esprit effectivement de lys trucks
c'était le 25 août dernier lors d'une
émission de télévision visant à
départager les deux finalistes au poste
de premier ministre alors question posée
à ces caches mais emmanuel macron friend
or le faux ami ou ennemi écoutez la
réponse
la question n'est pas tranchée
[Applaudissements]
si je deviens premier ministre je le
jugerai sur ses actes et pas sur ces
mots
il faudrait que le format était propice
à ces petites phrases alice 13 s'exprime
devant un parterre d'élus conservateurs
et la présentatrice julia haake les
brewers qui est elle-même catalogué à
droite elle vient de lui demander de
répondre du tac au tac comme ça avec des
petites phrases n'empêche cela laisse
songeur on aurait pu s'attendre à une
prise de parole plus diplomatiquement
correct diplomatiquement correct c'est
ce qu'a fait emmanuel macron lorsqu'il a
répondu c'était avant-hier cette semaine
il a été interrogé cette petite phrase
c'était lundi lors la conférence de
presse consacrée à la crise énergétique
écouter te dis bienvenue à l'iss trust
je lui exprime toutes les félicitations
de la france et nous sommes à
disposition pour pouvoir travailler
entre
comme on dirait alliés et amis quoi
qu'il advienne
nous devons sur le sujet d'énergie comme
sur d'autres
avoir une coopération renforcée nous
avons les mêmes valeurs nous avons une
histoire d'amitié nous sommes face à des
défis communs le royaume uni est un
grand pays qui est engagé avec nous pour
défendre les valeurs de la démocratie
aux côtés de l'ukraine et qui a besoin
aussi de renforcer sa souveraineté
énergétique et gagner la bataille du
changement climatique c'est ça les vrais
agenda le reste c'est l'écumé des jours
comment expliquer cette petite phrase de
liste ross et bien on l'a dit elle a été
prononcée le 25 août donc avant
l'élection au sein du parti conservateur
or pendant la campagne on l'a dit au
syli stress a tout fait pour revendiquer
l'héritage de boris johnson dont on sait
que les relations avec la france et
l'union européenne étaient notoirement
mauvaises lise trust se revendique comme
une farouche partisane du rexy tu
l'aurais mis le maquereau se veut le
chantre d'une union européenne unie en
faire un opposant même sur le ton de la
plaisanterie ça a donc pu servir sa
campagne sur le fond elle est aussi
opposée à la partie de l'accord du bric
site qui concerne la frontière nord
irlandaise et donc les discussions
s'annoncent particulièrement tendues sur
sept sujets là avec l'union européenne
et pour preuve on a vu ce tweet d'ursula
von der leyen saluant l élection de lys
très sain bravo ali stress nous sommes
confrontés à de nombreux défis ensemble
mais de finir en insistant j'attends
avec impatience une relation
constructive dans le plein respect de
nos accords le ton est donné aussi donc
côté européen merci quentin tout à
l'heure dans notre second débat on va
parler des relations avec l'europe dans
un instant d'abord si lieberman vous qui
avez été ambassadrice de france à
londres je le rappelle est ce que vous
avez en mémoire un mandat de deux
premiers ministres britanniques qui
démarre par une telle piques contre le
chef de l'état français
non mais là encore le break site est
passé par un parce qu'il ya eu des
oppositions effectivement comme cela a
été dit le président la république
française est un chantre de l'union
européenne et de l'autre côté il ya dans
ce vent une assistance pour mettre en
oeuvre le break 6 mais vraiment tout
effacer ce qui concerne l'union
européenne et que ça c'est toute la
législation tous les règlements
européens et donc ça change évidemment
là d'un homme étaient bons rails et
partenaires on l'est toujours mais
effectivement pas de la même manière sur
les questions européennes on est
aujourd'hui en opposition la question du
protocole nord-irlandais va revenir très
bientôt
possiblement
question de l'article 16 du côté
britannique et là on va se trouver dans
une relation quand je confie qu'elle pas
seulement avec la france mais avec
l'union européenne aujourd'hui le mot
brax insee un quasi taboue en fasse un
pas quasi c'est un tabou au royaume uni
tout ce qui va mal c'est soit la
conséquence du comme need sont la
conséquence de la guerre en ukraine et
jamais celle du haut du break 6 mais
c'est quand même de là que tout part et
cette question du protocole
nord-irlandais que les britanniques ont
signé les parlementaires ratifié trouvé
que c'était un accord extraordinaire
aujourd'hui ne veulent plus mais de
mettre en oeuvre mettant en danger le
marché unique européen avec la
possibilité de voir arriver des produits
qui ne respectent pas les conditions
sociales et environnementales
européennes donc ça sera beaucoup plus
difficile que ça me l'a été dans le
passé moi j'ai connu une période tout à
fait inédit des relations entre la
france et le royaume uni avec peut-être
pour les difficultés liées à
l'immigration qui revenait souvent mais
en dehors de ça on était très très
proches en particulier dans le domaine
de la défense alors pour vous avez
ouvert la porte de la question
européenne notamment de ce protocole
irlandais patrick martin jeunes il faut
peut-être rappeler en quelques mots ce
qui nuit à l'intérieur est effectivement
dire que l'histoire ça l'a évoqué l'idée
de le déchirer quoi oui alors c'est très
simple ce protocole aux irlandais comme
cela vient d'être rappelé arrêtez ça
devait régir de relations après le break
site mais surtout il avait un point
essentiel c'était faire en sorte que les
marchandises qui sortait d'angleterre
vers l'irlande du nord ne soient pas des
marchandises qu'ils allaient passer en
irlande est donc dans l'union européenne
et comme les accords du vendredi-saint
c'est à dire ce qu'ils ont permis de
sceller la paix entre les deux
communautés irlandais et protestants les
catholiques il ne fallait absolument pas
de frontière entre la république
d'irlande et l'irlande du nord il ne
fallait plus mettre des postes
frontières mais comme il fallait
protéger le marché intérieur il fallait
trouver un endroit où m -cd frontière
est donc le seul endroit c'était la
merde land du nord entre l'angleterre ou
l'ecosse et puis la langue du nord c'est
cela et donc c'est un accord qui a été
négocié rappelez-vous par michel barnier
à l'arraché jusqu'au fin décembre et
donc cela avait été signé donc unique
latéralement alors le dénoncer alors oui
un article comme madame donc vient de
dire si lieberman s'était acquis un
article 16 qui dit qu'à tout moment on
peut rompre unilatéralement cet accord
si il y à des difficultés d'application
tels qu'on ne peut plus l'appliquer mais
c'est une rupture qui peut-être du côté
britannique et du côté de l'union
européenne mais évidemment que l'union
européenne ne veut pas le faire et là la
difficulté c'est qu'en réalité tout ça
résulte d'un mensonge considérable de
boris johnson qui avait menti il a menti
à tout le monde il a menti aux
conservateurs il a menti aux loyalistes
protestants non irlandais je me rappelle
du réunion où il a dit jamais il n'y
aura de frontières dans la mer d'irlande
du nord et finalement c'était des
accords qu'il a signés donc il savait
dès le début que l'accord qu'ils avaient
signés étaient impraticables et
aujourd'hui et bien les différents
ministres sont cassés les dents dessus
c'est toujours potentiellement une crise
avec l'union européenne et en tant que
ministre des affaires étrangères elle
même a menacé de mettre en oeuvre cet
article 16 de ronde et d'ailleurs elle a
elle-même déposé une proposition de loi
au parlement britannique pour renégocier
entièrement les termes de ce protocole
ce qui est naturellement inacceptable vu
du côté de bruxelles sylvie bermann
disais à l'instant que le brésil c'était
presque le mot tabou en ce moment en
grande bretagne sacha mitchell est ce
que les pros brésil sont sur majorité on
en est ou parce que ça a pas mal évolué
l'état de l'opinion par rapport à ça
alors ça c'est assez difficile à dire je
c'est assez difficile à dire je suis pas
certains sondages récents à ce sujet je
pense que pour la majorité de la
population c'est fait et on en sort on
est obligé d'en parler dans tous les cas
et je pense que là la petite sortie de
li strauss s'inscrit dans ce cadre là
parce que il ya une une vision chez une
aile droite des conservateurs et dans
une partie de la presse conservatrice
qui est que emmanuel macron et l'union
européenne cherche toujours à punir le
royaume uni pour le bric site il cherche
à punir le royaume uni pas pour le bric
cite notamment sur la question d'en rire
landais justement parce que selon alors
le gouvernement de boris johnson avant
lui mais lisse trust a repris cette idée
là l'union européenne applique ce
protocole nord-irlandais de manière trop
strictes selon il y aurait de la marge
d'une marge de manoeuvre on pourrait
exempté de contrôles douaniers dans les
ports britanniques les par exemple les
marchandises qui sont à destination
uniquement de l'irlande du nord et qui
sont pas ensuite destinés à la
république d'irlande et à l'union
européenne mais il ya cette voix là il
ya sept cette croyance là qui perdure et
avec la france est aussi la question des
traversées illégal delà de la manche en
tout cas les traversées de la manche sur
des petites embarcations de fortune
londres estime que la france ne fait pas
assez pour les pour les empêcher il y
avait aussi les
les embouteillages monstrueux auquel on
a assisté cet été à douvres pour les
vacanciers britanniques mais aussi les
camions de marchandises pour des
fonctions qui seront encore et de sel
pour une friction encore non bio lui
aussi la pêche ce dont on a dont on n'a
pas parlé et on pourrait évoquer je
voudrais juste heureux répondre la main
pardon de vous interrompre pour évoquer
nos cinq minutes
l'affiliation en quelque sorte entre
lyss trust et boris johnson s'est elle
même qui en parle dans son l'un de ses
tout premiers discours l'une de ses
premières prises de parole que doivent
tenu
qu'un set je viens d'accepter la
cordiale invitation de sa majesté la
reine à former un nouveau gouvernement
je veux rendre hommage à mon
prédécesseur boris johnson a mis en
oeuvre le brésil le vaccin contre le coc
vie et s'est dressé contre l'agression
russe l'histoire le verra comme un
immense premier ministre je suis honoré
d'assumer cette responsabilité à un
moment vital pour notre pays
l'histoire le verra comme un immense
premier ministre sarah pickard c'est ça
n'est pas surprenant de l'entendre dire
ça pour quoi ce qui me choque c'est
qu'elle ait dit rien sur le fait que
boris johnson pourquoi les partis c'est
parce que ses députés l'ampli de partir
et qu'il y en a enlevé stig à sion ce
moment pour mons anges devant le
parlement et au lieu de dire que c'est
comme si c'était au pouvait onglet quoi
au lieu des 10 rebonds on va on va
gouverner de façon honnête transparent
etc elle fait des éloges c'est choquant
je trouve
surtout
la méthode vous voulez nous dire ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que le peuple
avait marre de 10 johnson tous les
mensonges comment il a géré de kovy dit
que c'est hier à c'est pas anti gates
etc c'est un homme qui a menti c'est pas
moi qui ai bien du monde qui a menti
devant le parlement et que au lieu de se
distancier elle essaye doit encore
chirier les personnes fidèles à johnson
et et de le faire donc c'est pas une
nouvelle façon de gouverner et pourquoi
elle le veut parce qu'elle va rester
populaire parmi les adhérents du parti
et que créer peut-être aussi parce
qu'elle lui doit en partie son élection
à ce qu'on peut dire salvatrice bien sûr
elle doit sa carrière politique à boris
johnson c'est grâce à lui qu'elle est
devenue première ministre faut savoir
une chose c'est que le clan johnson et
quand on est quand même très important
au sein du parti conservateur et déjà il
ya déjà des rumeurs qui disent que boris
johnson voudrait revenir et perruches et
n'a pas dit son dernier mot parce que
c'est lui qui a le plus implantation au
sein du parlement dockal dis ça parce
qu'elle doit son élection aborigènes
sonne elle n'est pas partie et c'est
grâce à lui qu'elle est devenu premier
ministre un dernier mot sylvie bermann
sur justement cette filiation lille
strasbourg hills
johnson est est-ce qu'il va peut-être
quand même devoir s'en démarquer dans
les prochains jours dans les prochaines
semaines trouver son positionnement
sa patte en quelque sorte oui mais en
même temps elle a absolument besoin de
son soutien c'est très dangereuse s'il
était critique il a dit qu'il serait
loyal ou fair play je ne sais plus quel
terme il a il a employé et puisqu'elle
se compare à mark thatcher il ya un
souvenir qui celui de l'éviction de
marianne pelchat et de la
nomination de john major comme premier
ministre et margaret thatcher qu'il se
trouvait écarté a rendu la vie
totalement impossible au nouveau premier
ministre john major et je pense qu'elle
n'a pas envie de se retrouver dans cette
situation là et que donc elle a intérêt
à le cultiver
vous avez gagné le pari dans l'émission
da mathieu g avant les vacances vous lui
donnez quelle durée de vie à ce poste de
premier c'est une c'est une très bonne
question je pense que ça dépendra de la
manière dont elle va répondre déjà 7 à
cette crise qui est qui et protéiforme
et on a on n'a pas parlé du système de
santé britannique aussi qu'étant indiqué
dans un état très très compliqué il ya
la crise de l'énergie à la guerre en
ukraine c'est une grande inconnue aussi
c'est assez c'est assez difficile à dire
je dirais autant que boris johnson au
moins d'accord en quelques mots patrick
mahé
lorsque elle a six mois pour faire ses
preuves si au bout de six mois ça ne
marche pas elle sera renversée et si
elle voit que ça ça ça va cahin caha
mais elle restera jusqu'en 2024 mais sur
12 sera t-elle battu par les
travaillistes et rapide mais la même
chose je pense qu'ils vont vouloir la
garder jusqu'au bout comme ça elle elle
prend toutes les critiques si ça va pas
et après on change de premier ministre
après les prochaines élections bien on
verra on suivra ça dans les prochains
mois merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat qui était passionnant à bientôt
sur sur public sénat